[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci nous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro de vie pose
aujourd'hui nous recevant le docteur
philippe charlier philippe charlier
bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation la dernière fois vous
étiez venu en voisin car vous êtes à
cause de ça mais vous êtes médecin
légiste anthropologue maître de
conférences à lui avais lu vs q donc à
côté d'ici et vous êtes aussi auteur
donc vous êtes souvent dans les yvelines
grâce à ce à cette fonction vous nous
aviez parlé de trois livres la dernière
fois la science export l'histoire le top
6 des mots célèbre et zombies voilà
aujourd'hui vous êtes là pour un nouveau
livre qui sort chez tallandier le top 6
des fantômes une histoire du surnaturel
que voici
voilà alors ma première question
après on passera des choses peut-être
plus sérieuse est ce qu enfant vous avez
cru aux fantômes à c'était compliqué non
je n'ai plus peur que oui un requin qui
passe dans la chambre qui me croque
après avoir vu certains films qui font
un tout petit peu peur ou est ce genre
de peurs totalement irrationnel mais non
les fantômes non j'avais conscience
quand j'étais petit que le monde ait un
tout petit peu plus complexe que ce que
mes yeux pouvait voir c'était simplement
mais rien d'extraordinaire à ch et 2 à
creuser de ce côté là ok alors on oublie
bon alors dans ce cas là vous médecin
vous cartésien vous aux hommes de
science pourquoi s'intéresser à un tel
sujet alors que vous savez pertinemment
que les fantômes n'existe pas ce qui
m'intéressait c'était pas tant de savoir
si les fantômes existent et où
n'existaient pas c'était plutôt de faire
une démarche d'anthropologues et de
poser la question de pourquoi les gens
ont envie d'y croire pourquoi est ce que
les gens font semblant parfois d'y
croire en gros à quoi servent les
fantômes qu'est ce qui est le légitimise
leur présence et cette crédulité
c'était ça vraiment qu'ils me qui
m'intéressait je suis parti à l'ours
quelques sources historiques anciennes
l'antiquité grecque romaine le moyen-age
la renaissance
et puis surtout ce grand âge d'or du
spiritisme qui est celui de la fin du
18ème minute
neuvième siècle et jo j'ai il est très
scientifique il est très sensible c'est
parce que la science occupe tout
l'espace que eh bien certains qui sont
adeptes du merveilleux et qui rêve qui
refuse vraiment cette totalitarisme de
la science se réfugie dans l'autre monde
dans les fantômes et dans le surnaturel
d'accord et alors quels sont les
critères requis pour être amenés à
croire aux fantômes
est-ce que femme j'imagine on a
l'impression qu'il faut peut-être avoir
eu des deuils de proches des morts
précoces qu'on a du mal à accepter à
avaler est ce que il ya tout un tas de
choses est-ce qu'on s'ennuie parce que
par exemple au 19ème fin du système ça
peut être aussi une bonne distraction
qui sont ces gens qui veulent y croire
alors à l'époque on n'a pas la radio on
n'a pas la télévision le soir qu'est ce
qu'on fait on joue du piano ou des
instruments de musique qu'on le fait de
la lecture à voix haute
parfois à voix basse on a des jeux de
cartes tric trac et cetera
on peut faire de la couture fumeur de
cigares par de l'alcool bref pas mal de
jeu d'occupation qui sont possibles le
spiritisme rentre très bien là dedans on
peut faire tourner les cartes
et puis c'est surtout c'est tout sauf un
échappatoire c'est vraiment ça c'est un
échappatoire
soit parce qu'on a été touchée de façon
extrêmement forte par des deuils par des
drames choix parce que eh bien on est
d'un niveau socio économique très très
bas ou en très très très haut et donc on
le prend soin comme un signe d'élite on
va dialoguer avec des grands de ce monde
qui ont disparu je le sais car jésus
saint pol pot encore
ou alors vraiment un nouveau payer la
vie sur terre est vraiment extrêmement
dure et là c'est une bouffée d'oxygène
vers l'autre monde ans vers un monde
inconnu et qui permet de couvrir la
fenêtre tout simplement on sait ya un
besoin il ya vraiment un besoin qui est
à combler le spiritisme est là pour ça
pour supporter la une vie parfois très
très dur et est ce que vous pensez que
le cerveau peut se mettre en état de
d'autosuggestion justement c'est chez
gens là pour qui s'auto persuadent comme
un mécanisme de défense à la douleur que
oui oui ils ont bien vu
le fantôme il pas cela tous les jours où
c'est ma grand mère un achat etc
alors ça c'est une question je me suis
pas posé mois à nouveau le travail était
plus anthropologique que médical moi ce
qui m'intéressait plus c'était pourquoi
les gens sont amenés à y croire mais pas
la mise en condition et pas quasiment
une analyse neuro neuropsychiatriques ou
neuro psychologique c'était pas ça en
revanche quand on travaille sur certains
écrits notamment les écrits de victor
hugo
quand il est un jersey avant d'aller à
gaza et que il explore totalement ce
monde spirit pendant de longs mois
on sent encore que tous les écrits qui
ne va laisser en l'occurrence il va
transcrire des choses qui sont dictées
qu'il dit mais parle par la table le
guéridon je qualifie les séances en fait
celle victor hugo lorsque dans le sexy
pim lorsque même shakespeare s'exprime
en français entendu parce que c'est une
langue plus belle que l'anglais dit il
est bien à chaque fois c'est du victor
hugo donc peut-être que cette façon de
répondre à votre question d'accord après
on peut parler aussi fois j'ai lu ça
dans un livre sus par hasard c'était
livre de janet une personne hôtel qui se
passe en angleterre elle dit que le 19e
siècle et début du xxème et l ère des
fantômes et du gua et de l'éclairage au
gaz et que ce monoxyde de carbone alors
encore une fois ce n'était pas ce que
vous avez cherché à explorer mais le
monoxyde de carbone pouvait provoquer
des légers délits et faire parce qu'en
fait ces gens qui croient il ya des
choses qui voit tout de même
oui j'ose qu'il voit il ya
l'autosuggestion millet beaucoup de
trucage vous vous verrez d'ailleurs rien
dans cet ouvrage
oui je l'avais lu ce qu il y a beaucoup
de trucage malheureusement qui viennent
gâtés un tout petit peu la crédulité de
et belle histoire
beaucoup de gens riches et d'ailleurs
pour les adeptes réalisme quelques
affiches on dit ah non mais c'est un bon
spirit un bon média mme merkel est en
forme donc besoin de céder un tout petit
peu mais il faut lui faire confiance
pour les antilles spirits a sacré un
sérieux doute pour pas dire d'autre
alors mais authentique se disent non on
a parfois besoin d'un petit coup de
pouce
bah oui on nul n'est infaillible et
alors du coup qui sont ces gens qui
veulent à tout prix faire croire aux
fantômes est ce que c'est juste pour
l'argent ou est-ce qu'ils sont persuadés
eux mêmes de leurs affaires
il y en a beaucoup qui font cette façon
on va dire délictuelle ou criminelle
oui par exemple les photographies spirit
sont injustes marché où on se fait
photographier avec le l'ombre si on peut
dire en tout cas le spectre apparaissant
sur la non pas la pellicule mais sur la
plaque d'argent avec métallique et
c'était quelqu'un qui a disparu mais
c'est un fake c'est un site info c'est
une menace d'une fermeture complète
réalisée par le par le photographe
tout simplement parce qu'un jeu qu'on
s'est rendu compte qu'il avait faite par
accident une double exposition et s'est
dit qu'au marché juteux à la géniale je
vais en profiter je vais je vais faire
de l'argent là dessus donc là on est
vraiment quelque chose de délictuelles
pareil pour d'autres des médiums qui
font dématérialisation
en fait ils sont très vite le tour était
joué et si l'on peut dire ils ont très
vite mis à nu et on se rend compte le
chant se sont déguisés qui se sont
transformés pour apparaître sous les
traits d'un fantôme jeunes ont été
réalisés donc c'est faux gâche beaucoup
la sincérité de certains spirit ou
médium pied réel leur sincérité en tout
cas elle est réelle d'accord il y en a
quand même qui skie qu'il faut ça on y
croyait dur comme fer
il faut pas s'imaginer que la communauté
spirit je rappelle qu'on est toujours au
19e siècle du 20e il faut pas s'imaginer
que c'est un ensemble
l'escroc surtout pas ça très bien et
alors justement aujourd'hui vous vous
êtes allez un petit peu voir aussi ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui vous êtes allé
par exemple lit et me l'institut
métapsychique international qui est
établi dans le nord de paris qui est une
institution si on peut dire déclare
utilité publique donc qui est sourd
autorités distante mais réelle du
ministère de l'intérieur et qui a pour
charge d'enquêter à chaque fois sur les
cas les cas bizarre alors certes 90% des
coups de téléphone qui reçoivent à peu
près aboutissent finalement dans les
mains de psychologues sinon quand même
mais dans 10 % malgré tout et bien il ya
les enquêtes supplémentaires qui sont
réalisées des entretiens des
déplacements sur place pour enregistrer
donc l'idée c'est que tout n'est pas
explicable mais que la science doit
essayer d'expliquer au maximum et
surtout ils ont des archives monstrueuse
des archives extraordinaire d'entretien
de photographies de matérialisation mise
en place ou rouen si bas c'est toute
l'histoire de l'armée d'immunité du
spiritisme dès le départ qu'ils sont
conservés dans les archives de vie émis
à paris donc si on voit quelque chose
d'étrange chez soi des tableaux qui
bouge ou des fans importe quoi
des fantômes qui se balade on les
appelle oui par exemple le fantôme que
juste derrière vous vous pourriez vous
pourriez appeler la normale mais vous
parce que je veux pas c'est vous qui
voyez
en plus des numéros c'est qui bon bref
mais alors je j'insiste encore mais les
deux les médiums qui disent rentrer en
contact avec l'au delà avec des esprits
ça c'est donc la question n'est pas de
savoir si c'est vrai ou faux ma question
est de savoir pourquoi est-ce qu'en ce
moment avec la période de lakovic 19
pourquoi est ce qu'il ya une énorme
reconnaissance de ce style de le
contacter si on peut dire et à la
patience
principalement parce que il y a que des
politiques et pandémiques demande de m r
on n'assiste pas beaucoup mal à faire un
deuil est donc parfois bien pour
certains ces séances de spiritisme 0 de
rentrer dans le bail est de faire une
sorte de continuité permet d'accepter la
mort la distance et la disparition du
défunt d'assouvir un peu la frustration
de n'avoir pu être présent lors de la
mort et de rattraper un moment qui n'a
pas existé quelque part c'est ça oui
assouplir cette un soupir cette
frustration oui la rendre la rendre
digeste
au fur et à mesure
paré par ceux ci d'accord donc c'est une
très bonne période pour les médias en ce
moment normalement ils font florès oui
tout à fait très bien et alors vous vous
la mort vous fait peur vous êtes sûr
qu'il y a rien derrière vous je sais ce
que je veux a les idées toi moi j'en ai
pas la moindre idée jean jeu extrêmement
curieux de savoir bien entendu mais je
suis pas que le savoir tout de suite
ouverte petite fenêtre ouverte
vous savez des autopsies pendant dix ans
ne m'a pas ne m'a pas renseigné beaucoup
sur la mort ça m'arrange plus là bien
sûr ça m'a renseigné sur la
décomposition la putréfaction america
dégradation du corps après la mort mais
la mort à nancy plus dehors de la
religion ou de la métaphysique et salamé
sénégal n'est ni a maintenant le nom
c'est plus la technologie c'est plus la
confrontation avec d'autres religions
d'autres cultures
je pense au vaudou doit ici un vaudou
béninois au bouddhisme principalement de
l'himalaya qui décrit très bien les
processus de la mort comme une
extinction progressive de différentes
lumières à l'intérieur du club m'ont pas
comme un événement brutal et immédiat
donc tout ceci tout ceci rend sengoku
voilà et met sur le chemin d'une
compréhension de son appel la mort sa
chance
probablement il ya des morts on ne meurt
pas toujours de la même façon dire plein
de morts différentes alors sable autre
chose bon bah écoutez ono bahreïn est
faux parce que l'émission est terminée
un grand merci votre prochain livre on
peut savoir de quoi il va parler
oui mon prochain livre et s'intitulera
comment faire l'amour avec un fantôme
n'imaginait bien du tout c'est
simplement un voyage autour des fantômes
mais extra-européens cette fois ci est
le nom du livre vient de l'ouverture
d'un chapitre en au japon voilà tout
simplement où on a un culte particulier
vis-à-vis du breil les femmes mortes
dans des mauvaises conditions avec
lesquelles on peut ensuite
s'amuser très bien écouter merci
beaucoup j'encourage tout le monde à
lire ce livre qui est juste passionnant
on apprend énormément de choses et ça
nous ouvre plein de portes ou ou pas ou
sans referme d'autres enfin c'est selon
ce qu'on ressent un grand merci docteur
charlier et bas à très bientôt pour un
prochain livre très bientôt
on devrait en voir oui en vrai merci
[Musique]
il